we're now going to study the unit circle
a little bit more and uh see how it
extends
the i guess we could say the traditional
sohcahtoa
definitions of functions and how we can
actually use it to solve for angles that
the sohcahtoa definition of um of the
trig functions actually doesn't help us
with so let's just as a review remember
what sohcahtoa told us it told us
or or was that different i'll write it
up here in this corner i don't know how
how let's see so
i don't get confusing because i don't
want to write over too much soca
toa
and that told us i'm sorry i got it all
jumbled up here that told us that sine
if we have a right angle that the sine
of that of an angle in the right angle
is equal to the opposite
side over the hypotenuse the cosine of
an angle is equal to the adjacent side
of our hypotenuse and the tangent side
is equal to the opposite over the
adjacent side and this worked fine for
us but if you think about it what
happens when that angle approaches 90
degrees because you can't have two 90
degree angles in a right angle or what
happens when that angle is uh greater
than 90 degrees or what if it went
negative and that's why if you remember
from the previous video why we needed
the the unit circle definition
so let's
review the unit circle definition let me
erase this
i hope you can
let me erase i actually got this unit
circle i think i got it from wikipedia
but uh
i want to give due credit to whoever i
did get it for this this drawing of the
unit circle
but the unit circle uh kind of extends
that sohcahtoa definition it tells us
that if we have a unit circle and this
is a picture of a unit circle here a
unit circle is just a circle centered at
the origin centered at the point 0 0 and
it has a radius of 1 so it intersects
the x-axis at 1 0 and negative one comma
zero it intersects the y axis at zero
comma one
and zero comma negative one if we have a
unit circle we define um let's just say
let's let's start with the cosine of
theta we'd find the cosine of theta as
let's take an angle
that's between two radiuses
in this unit circle
and one radius is going to be
the positive x-axis between zero and one
so one radius is going to be this line
here
and then the and then we have the angle
is the angle between that bit kind of
you could kind of view that as the base
radius and some other radius so let's
say this case right here
and this is this would be our angle
the unit circle definition tells us that
the cosine of this angle is equal to the
x coordinate where this radius
intersects the unit circle
and that the sine of this function is
equal to the y-coordinate where this
point intersects the unit circle so for
example this
in this case if you can read behind
my my line this says 30 degrees equals
pi over 6. so this angle right here
is 30 degrees
or pi over 6
radians
pi over 6
radians and what this definition tells
us is that the sine of 30 degrees is one
half
and that the cosine of 30 degrees
is square root of three over two
and what i want to show you is that this
unit circle definition actually
coincides with our sohcahtoa
definition
but then it extends it so let's see how
we can get from that sokatoa definition
to this unit circle definition and why
they're actually consistent with each
other so let me erase some of what i
have
written here let me get the eraser tool
i'm going to erase
what i had
so let me
go back to the pen tool
make it
small again
okay i think i'm all set
so let's let's go back to that that
theta let's say that this is
the theta
and we we as we said this angle is 30
degrees or pi over 6.
let's drop
a line from that point
to the x-axis and as we see this line is
perpendicular so this is a 90 degree
angle
this is a 90 degree angle
and if this is a 30 degree angle here
this is 30
right theta equals 30 that says theta
equals 30. this is 30 this is 90. what
is this angle this is a 60 degree angle
right because they add up to 180. so
this is a 30-60-90 triangle interesting
and what do you remember about 30-60-90
triangles
well the side opposite the 30 degree
side is one half the length of the
hypotenuse
i hope you remember that i don't want to
confuse you too much
so this is the side opposite the 30
degree side right
and what's the hypotenuse this is the
hypotenuse and what's the length of this
hypotenuse well it's one because this is
a unit circle and this is a radius of
the unit circle so the length of this
hypotenuse is one
and then so
the the length of this side which is
opposite the 30 degree angle is going to
be one half
right and i'm just using
the 30 60 90 triangles
that we we've done previous videos on
and what's the side opposite the 60
degree side
well once again it's square root of 3
over 2 times the hypotenuse and so it's
square root of 3
over 2
right so we can figure out that this
side is square root of 3 over 2 and that
this side
is one half
so
a couple of things we can figure out
just by looking at this we can
immediately say well what's the
coordinates of this point
well its x coordinate is right here
right its x coordinate would be square
root of three over two that's this right
here this distance and its y coordinate
would be
the length of this side of the right
triangle or one half and there we have
it right here it was already written for
us the x coordinate is the square root
of three over two and the y coordinate
is one half
and now what i want to show you is why
this x coordinate can be taken as the
cosine of theta and why this y
coordinate can be taken as a sine of
theta well what is what does sohcahtoa
tell us well let's start with uh the
cosine so
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse right
cosine
is equal to
adjacent over hypotenuse
well in this
triangle i just drew what is the
adjacent side
to this angle right because we're trying
to figure out the cosine of this angle
this 30 degrees
well the co the adjacent side to this
angle is of course this side right
so adjacent to square root of 3 over 2.
we figured that out just now and what's
the hypotenuse well the hypotenuse is
this side
right which has
length 1 because it's a unit circle and
that's the radius of it so the cosine of
this angle using the sohcahtoa
definition is square root of 3 the
adjacent side
over the hypotenuse 1. so square root of
3 over 2 over 1 which is the square root
of 3 over 2
which was the same thing as the x
coordinate
similarly we could look at
so sine sine
equals opposite over hypotenuse sine
equals opposite over hypotenuse well
what's the opposite side it's one half
and the hypotenuse is one here
so the sine is just one half over one
and so we have it here and so that's why
the unit circle definition isn't kind of
a replacing definition for the sohcahtoa
definition it's really just an extension
that allows us i mean for 30 degrees
sohcahtoa worked for 45 degrees so
contour work works for 60 degrees it
would work
but once you get to 90 it becomes a
little bit more difficult right if you
use traditional sohcahtoa and you try to
draw a right triangle that has 290
degree angles in it because you couldn't
and especially once you get to angles
that are larger than 90 or angles that
actually could even go negative it's not
drawn here on the unit circle but 330
degrees is the same thing as negative 30
degrees because you could go either way
in the circle and you could keep going
around the circle you could figure out
the sine or the cosine of you know a
million degrees if you just keep going
around the circle
so hopefully this gives you a sense of
the unit circle definition of the the
sine and cosine functions and of course
the tangent function is always just the
sine
over the cosine over the or the y over
the x and and you could use the unit
circle definition for that as well
and and i'll leave it for you as an
exercise to try to drive all of these
other
values using this unit circle and using
what you already know about
30 60 90 triangles and what you already
know about 45 45 90 triangles or or what
you already know about the pythagorean
theorem and you should be able to figure
out
all of these values going around the
unit circle
hopefully that was helpful um see you
soon